the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so that that's a good start to
battlecode lecture to welcome today
we'll be talking about how to write your
first player and then at 6 p.m. we're
gonna be having some Indian food I'm
pretty excited and it looks like there
will be enough Indian food for all of
you I correctly estimated how many of
you would show up today
isn't that a curious aspect of
statistics that you cannot tell what one
person is going to do tomorrow but you
can tell very accurately what everyone
in aggregate is going to do tomorrow
quite interesting
I believe in 2006 the number of
automobile accident deaths was correctly
estimated to the last man or something
absolutely crazy like that because it's
a number like 40,000 and it was s it was
unbelievable so let with that with that
heartwarming opener about automobile
homicide I'm gonna play some slightly
less some slightly more calming images
so you'll see here on the screen is the
evolution of a very simple rule this
this rule is something like sum up the
number of nearest neighbors and if that
number is even then the Square will be
white in the next turn and if the number
is odd then the square will be black
it's something like that in in essence
and it ends up making this repeating
pattern that is quite mesmerizing to see
and is an excellent example of emergent
complexity so what we'll be doing today
is we're gonna write code that's pretty
darn simple a rule like you know mod 2
equals zero something like that and what
we're gonna get is some really awesome
looking behavior that comes out of that
very simple rule so there you go that's
my tie-in for that
administration stuff so here I've
brought up the battlecode website you
should all be set up with eclipse right
now already if you haven't then you're
falling behind but then again at the
same time you save yourself
some effort because we've just put out
another another release so what you want
to do is download the Installer and
install it to the same directory where
you currently have battle code and that
should update everything without
deleting the progress that you've made
on your player so there's that there's
also some exciting things I'm supposed
to be announcing that that will be an
hour we'll be giving away prizes for
things other than winning so if you're
if you're already if you're gonna see my
amazing code you're gonna go man I
didn't think I could do that well
although I find it much more likely that
you could watch what I'm gonna do and
then go I could have done that in my
sleep I can't believe this guy but what
yeah we'll be giving away prizes for
doing things other than winning this
year and those things I'll be announcing
throughout the year so you can like keep
them in the back of your mind and be
like oh I I sort of have code that kind
of does that I should I should think
about doing this they'll be beating the
reference player with the fewest total
byte codes of beating the reference
player in the shortest possible time by
the way we haven't released a reference
player we will be releasing one within
the next couple of weeks and I don't
know if I've said it yet but to get
credit for the course you have to beat
the reference player that we that will
provide on a map set that we provide so
it'll be called reference player and
you'll and there'll be more information
about that later you're also able to get
credit by writing a short report on how
your code works if you weren't able to
beat the reference player so don't don't
fret too much so those two ways are ways
of winning money you can also have the
most interesting use of our source code
like if you want to like make it so that
nan nan cats are part of battle code or
some other silly thing that that might
get you something and there's also most
impressive non winning strategy which
may very well be the thing that we see
today all right so here I'm gonna go to
eclipse this is our supported
development environment and I'm gonna
start setting up a new player so this is
I've got all these extra battlecode
installs because of the development
nonsense that went on so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna just start from scratch
and I'm gonna make sure that I talk
about the functions that I'm using in
ways that are useful to both beginners
and intermediate people so beginners
have to like hurry to catch up and
intermitted people are more hearing
about the battlecode api and hearing
about like how things are put together
specifically about battlecode that they
wouldn't already know from their java
experience for example so let's let's
start this way I'm going to make a new
team that I can that I can fight against
my other teams that are here because I
want to keep trying this you know a big
thing about programming is making it
iterative all iterable iterable interval
implements runnable anyway these kinds
of things and so you'll want to have
like a bunch of different robots that
can play against one another and so you
can be like all right I'm gonna
right-click this team's folder and I'm
gonna go to create package and I'm gonna
call it what's a good name for this
awesome robot that we're gonna make yeah
awesome robot okay play awesome robot
player I I guess that's that's decent
yeah and then in this one I go new file
and I call it robot player Java it has
to be called that because that's the
thing that our game engine is looking
for so then at the very top we're gonna
write down a package awesome robot
player and and then we're gonna put a
semicolon yeah cuz you got to do that
then we'll import everything in battle
code so we can use the battle code the
battle code API which is here in battle
code common dot star so that'll give us
everything that's in the Java Doc's so
what I'll sort of want to do is have
open the Java Doc's
it maybe in one window or on the side
and have open this in another window so
that could sort of bounce back between
them I'm not going to do that at the
moment because that would make things
even harder to see so what I'm
do here is I'm gonna increase the text
size because I know some of you at the
back I'm not gonna be able to see a
hundred percent of what I'm doing if you
want to follow along on your laptop's go
ahead I believe I'll I'll believe we'll
be able to post this code after lectures
so don't worry too much about like
making sure that you can type as slowly
as I can
awesome is that too big it might be here
we're gonna do we're just gonna we're
just going to run straight in so public
class robot player you got to write that
so now okay so you've written that the
Java IDE you can note you notice will
put these brackets in for us real nice
and you need a a run method public
static void run and that's going to take
the argument robot controller and then
you can name it whatever you want I I
generally call it my RC so this robot
controller object is the thing that is a
robot so when you run this code every
robot has its is its own my RC and so
the methods of my RC which you'll see
later will apply to that particular
robot you'll see some examples so what I
like to do is I like to make I like to
define the variable for this robot
controller object I like to define a
variable so it can be used throughout
this class that throughout this package
so I'm going to type private static
robot controller RC and RC is going to
be the thing that I define to my RC I'm
just gonna say there you are now you've
got it and I can use all of the methods
in robot controller by typing RC dot and
then bingo right there you see eclipse
is telling me all of the methods that
are in the battle code common directory
you know there are all these methods
that you can use so right here it's like
this is a really convenient way of doing
things and so you're gonna see you're
going to see that throughout today's
lecture so what I want to do is I want
to make sure that I've got everything
organized in a way that I can use it
because I'm sure everybody here has
written code in some language or other
that just goes on and
it's it's like absolutely massive and so
every time you want to make a change
down here and up here and down here
oh here but you just sort of get a
headache and you have to fall over and
it's not it's not very good because you
could be at edit elevation and falling
over at elevation is highly damaging so
what we want is this method will run but
if we only run it like this let's see
what happens can can any of you guess
what's gonna happen if we run awesome
robot player that's right it's gonna die
can you tell me why it's gonna die
that's right that's right because run
will reach the end of a method so both
of the teams explode I'm kind of curious
which team won that match let's see here
it says they both died ah team a one
good thing to know team a will win if
both teams die so let's let's make a
while true yeah yeah all right the
game's unbalanced I recognize that
well we'll patch it in I don't know in
two seconds or ten minutes or whatever
we're up to did I mention that we're up
to one point one point zero so
definitely go and install that one point
one point one that's so fast
our development cycle is amazing so
while true
we'll just keep looping and so let's try
this let's do while true what's gonna
happen can anybody tell me what's gonna
happen when I do Wow true that something
that's undesirable these guys are going
to use 10000 byte codes because they
just keep looping while true while true
wall true while true and I guess this
one comparison this will like going to
the end of loop and come to the top I
guess costs some nonzero amount so they
end up reaching their bytecode limit
that's no good so if we do RC yield that
ends the turn so whatever happens here
above RC yield will happen and then
it'll go to the next round so now the
bytecode usage for each robot you'll see
and right now all we've got are these
headquarters robots the byte codes used
is 3 I'll just have to read it out
because it's so small you can't see yeah
yeah it's three so that's that's
fantastic that's like the minimum that
you can get alright so now we're gonna
put real stuff in we want the
headquarters to behave differently from
the robots for example because the
headquarters can never move you know it
can't walk around so let's use if RC dot
now what we want is we want to figure
out like what type of robot it is so
let's look at the at the different
options here oh look there is an RC dot
get type yeah all right so now we can
just say if that equals robot type dot
soldier that's not what I wanted sold
yeah if it's a soldier then we can like
put soldier code here and otherwise we
can put like headquarters code here so
let's make a very simple a very simple
thing like let's say we want to just
kill the enemy kill them kill them dead
so let's have let's have us do this we
will define a new variable right here
now in this space Direction derp equals
RC get location dot Direction 2 and now
we'll just like we want to go straight
to the enemy we want to we want to make
we want to find the direction to the
enemy and then when we want to go that
direction so it's telling me there's an
error because the direction two needs a
direction to what so let's give it a
location we're gonna give it the
location RC dot sense enemy HQ location
so there you go now we're we're out
we've already got the direction I'm
gonna put a semicolon at the end of the
line and now I can see all right I'm
gonna try to go that direction to move
in a direction you gotta be active
because there are certain things you can
do like laying mines and defusing them
that make you inactive so I'm gonna I'm
gonna check if I'm active
if RC dot is active which returns a
boolean true if I'm active well then
let's go ahead and try to move and we'll
see what happens when we try this RC dot
move in Direction dirt and so now we're
gonna we're just gonna see we're gonna
see what happens
oh what's this it's telling me that an
unhandled exception is here move can
throw exceptions and so what we do is we
put in add throws declaration
so then up here robot controller is
gonna throw an error if this thing has a
problem and this is this is a way that
you can use this is Java's built in form
of debugging and you're gonna find it
very useful because when you have a
problem it'll tell you what the problem
is so let's go ahead and do that hmm
well the problem is we don't have any
soldiers we can't produce any units so
you know there's nobody who can run this
code so let's go ahead and add in some
unit spawning abilities right over here
so I'm gonna go to example funks player
open up robot robot player java and i'm
gonna copy this part which is for if the
robot is a headquarters and i'm just
gonna go ahead and paste it right in
there and now all of a sudden i'm
spawning units at random directions
around myself as the headquarters so now
we should have units in our awesome
robot player and they start to run at
one another but something strange is
happening when they run into one another
it seems like they're immediately
colliding and exploding boom that one
exploded and then that one exploded and
that one did that's sort of weird
looking isn't it it almost looks like
this guy is changing color but no
they're they're running into each other
and exploding and the problem it's not
just that they're going too fast cuz
that isn't the thing it's that there's a
game action exception and you can see
here that like there's tons of
exceptions and they all showed up here
and I can be like okay I don't
understand anything at all I I can't
read any of this language oh but look it
says robot player dot Java : 15 I can
just click there and shows me what
what's throwing the exception oh it's
this line oh I see I see it's having
trouble moving there because maybe
there's something in the way so let's
also stipulate that our C dot can move
in the direction this is another method
that's provided to you that lets you
check whether the direction is movable
so now when we run the code they're
gonna just go to the middle kiss and
kill each other nice and slow just like
that Wow oh that's beautiful
I think that's just gonna happen all day
long until the end of C when you get
past a certain number of rounds the
headquarters begin to take end-of-round
damage so you can see the headquarters
you're just gonna die and that happens
and they both die at once and I believe
player a will have won oh no player B
won now let me tell you
that's balanced yeah yeah so we know
what we're doing and that's all right
this is getting sort of this is starting
to get kind of cluttered right this is
I'm not happy with this I not a neat
freak my wife kind of is no I shouldn't
say anything about my wife on this
because gonna be recorded she's not a
neat freak she's very wonderful woman
the okay so god I'm in so much trouble
all right all right so here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna make a new method
that'll clean the place up we'll call it
public static void we'll call it we'll
call it HQ code this is the headquarters
code and it's the stuff that I want the
headquarters to do and I'm just gonna
copy this in here and then I'm gonna put
HQ code there Bing so now I'm calling
this method which I've defined below and
that'll just that'll just sort of like
insert that code right right in there
really convenient now can anybody tell
me why there's a red underline under
spawn yeah a game action exception so
what will happen is I'll just click on
this button and now this code will have
this guy will throw the exception so
exceptions from here will throw up and
they'll throw it here and then they'll
throw even more now let's say let's say
that we don't want to throw them all the
way up to the top because you don't want
run to ever throw an exception because
it causes your robot to explode so how
do you how do you prevent thrown things
from getting out like like if if Billy
throws me a football how do I keep the
football from hitting my house which is
behind me that's right I catch it okay
and in Java the way that that's done I
know a lot of you know this already but
some of you don't and you're gonna think
that was a really clever analogy is you
put try on the outside all right and
then you put I think I put it I think I
want to put it here I want to put catch
here yeah and so specifically I want to
make sure that I catch the exception so
I'll go I'll catch exception E which
will be whatever exception comes out of
try will go into E now you see that the
tabbing is messed up because try should
have a tab after it so I just highlight
this
I and that that automatically tabs it
out 95% of you knew that already but the
1% the 5% I can a can add the 5% that
didn't know I like oh that save me so
much time I'm so happy
yes so we're going to catch the
exception and then we're gonna do system
dot out dot print line and we're just
gonna say like you know caught exception
before it killed us yeah and we're gonna
just print it so we're gonna go eat dot
print stack trace and we'll pick the
third one because it looks good yeah so
now when there's an error it'll just
print down to here rather than killing
the robot at the same time I should
mention that anytime a try finds an
error and moves to catch you get 500
byte code penalty right there so that's
like not a great way to write code you
want to avoid you want to avoid having
the exceptions at all all right all
right but we're getting sort of stuck
because we haven't had as much killing
as we really wanted to have so I've got
an idea for how to make code that kills
other that that kills the enemy so let's
let's go with that idea that I have that
I definitely have and I'm not coming up
with on the spot so that let's that was
a joke I actually am NOT coming up with
it on the spot I'm so offended that you
didn't find that it was joke I just have
to find out where it is in the notes
it's in it's in capture and can't
mention oh yeah let's let's not capture
an encampment yet cuz that's not as
exciting is because you know what we
would really like to do is just you know
defeat the enemy and then we'll worry
about like sort of shaming them into a
greater defeat subsequently so let's see
here if you're a soldier maybe the right
thing to do is sort of start by massing
up your troops in a place so let's get a
place to mass up the troops now maybe
you only want to do this once like a
it's sort of like a rally point for
everybody so let's let's get this rally
point I'm gonna make it here because I
want everybody to know where this route
this rally point is so a rally point
maplocation because you want everybody
the sort of localized around a place now
a map location is yet another object
like like robot controller and it has
its own methods and and you know
properties associated with it that you
can find in the Java Docs and that you
can call and it you can find your own
way so let's do this map location rally
point
yeah we're just going to rally somewhere
this is a real this is gonna be a good
strategy trust me it's gonna be you're
gonna be excited so let's do let's find
the rally points start out so let's
let's make a function because it's
already getting you know far too far too
fluffy I think so let's find the rally
point here will say rally point equals
find rally point
yeah now where where should we rally I
think a decent place oh look at this
it's even gonna help me out here it
noticed that there's no method so I can
just click here and it'll make me a nice
method look at that it's just like this
HQ code with the private static and then
it has the type that it returns see this
time is we're making a function that
returns a type this didn't return
anything it just it just made it just
did code here but now we want it to like
spit out an answer so we're gonna have
it return a map location when it's done
so what we'll do is we're gonna get some
location between us and the enemy seems
like a great place to rally our troops
so between us and the enemy let's see
the enemy location so I'm just going to
make this nice and simple map location
enemy lock even define variables anyway
this will be local to this function the
enemy location is our C dot sense enemy
yeah there sense enemy hit okay map
location our location is our C dot sense
HQ location yeah and now I want to find
sort of the average I'm not going to do
it in the smartest possible way I'm
gonna do it in a way that's easy to
understand is I'm gonna say there's an
integer X which is enemy location dot X
plus our location dot X all right now I
guess if you took the average of the two
that would be in between right that
would be in in between the two but we
don't want it completely in between the
two because we want to sort of just you
know move a little bit out so let's make
it more of our LOC and less of
they're so three of ours and now when
you put a multiply and that should get
us one quarter of the way to the enemy
because it's mostly us and somewhat them
yeah we'll do that for y as well
there's probably smarter ways of doing
it than just writing out two lines but
it's very it's pretty clear and now what
we'll do is we use the constructor for
map location
so we'll say map location rally point
equals new map location and we give it
an X and a y yeah yeah all right now we
can just say return rally point okay so
now we're gonna try to go to the rally
point
rally point has been defined here that's
useful
so now later we don't have to give it a
direction we can just say Direction D R
equals get location dot direction to
that will go to the rally point instead
yes yes to the rally point
rarely point let's see if our robots are
going to the rally point I recommend
that you try running your code every
time you make a significant change and
look they did they went to the rally
point but yeah they kind of went there
in a dumb way because when one of them
was in front of the other they couldn't
go around they need someone because now
this guy can't spawn any more robots I'm
pretty sure he's trying but it's not
working
in fact what what error am I getting
here I'm getting you cannot move in the
direction none or Omni that's an
interesting problem that's the problem
that when a robot is on top of the spot
he shouldn't try to move to the spot
that he's on top of so we should also
specify that there's a distance and he
should only try moving if there's a
distance so let's just put int dist
r c dot get location dot if you always
do that too I always put i before o dot
distance squared to and distance squared
to rally point yes that's that's a
useful method there are a lot of useful
methods for get location and you might
say all right how was I supposed to know
the distance squared to was a method
from get location I was gonna write my
own manual function that goes looking
for X's and Y's and squaring them and
subtracting them and so on
not that subtraction is really even
relevant here
but how was I supposed to know well I'll
tell you how you were supposed to know
you just go to the you just go to where
you installed it I put it in battlecode
2013 you go to doc and you go to the to
this thing all classes frame and this
shows you all of the classes one of
those classes here is map location and
under map application you see that you
can add map locations to directions you
can add them to X's and Y's you can use
direction to distance squared you can
check whether to map locations are equal
to one another if they're adjacent to
one other that's pretty useful so you
know having a sort of a working
understanding or sort of memorization of
these things will help you along the way
so let's now we've got distance squared
to so now we only want to move toward
the enemy if so if our distance is
greater than zero then we'll try moving
there otherwise let's not because it's
just gonna end up giving us trouble and
I'm once again I'm gonna do control I to
do this indenting but this is getting
somewhat cluttered so why don't I just
make this soldier code especially here
when when everything is a giant font
sixteen so this is soldier code and I'll
just go ahead and have it automatically
create me that method I'm gonna go ahead
and put this in the method and now our C
dot move has got a throw declaration you
see this I like pretty soon I'm not even
need to be here because it's doing
everything for me my goodness so now
they should go to the rally point and
they shouldn't be throwing quite as many
exceptions as they were before oh look
at that
in the game output window you see no
exceptions from around zero to five
thousand excellent but again they're
just sort of stuck behind one another
how can we make it so that they're not
stuck well here's a good way to do it
so here you're only trying one direction
but now let's make a way to try multiple
directions the way that I'm about to
show you has its own emergent complexity
built in you're gonna like this a lot I
believe so yes let's do it
let's define a list now lists are
defined this way you put an open square
bracket and I'm gonna make a list of
integers because I'm gonna try I'm also
gonna use some tricks for direction
because a lot of you were probably
thinking oh gosh I noticed in the Java
Docs that direction here I'm gonna go to
Java Docs again Direction is here and
there's all there's all these directions
east north-northeast bla there are eight
directions I can rotate them left and
right but am I really gonna enjoy
rotating them again and again to find
you know which direction I'm going to
like okay I could go forward if forward
is blocked then rotate the direction
left if the left is blocked then rotated
now that would be actually really
annoying to right and and it's not the
most elegant way to do it the way we're
going to do it is we're going to get the
direction values and then we're going to
use the direction list so the direction
list consists of these eight things I
believe it starts at North and then it
goes around to Northwest and so
Direction lists at zero is north and so
I'm going to show you how we're going to
do that and what amazing result it has
because a lot of you already know how to
code but you don't know what amazing
result is gonna have or maybe you do so
this integer I'm going to call the
direction offsets and you can define an
integer list by setting it equal to this
construct so I'm just going to put curly
brackets and now I'm going to do 0 1
minus 1 2 minus 2 yes so that now gets
me some Direction offsets and I need to
start checking directions so I'll use
for direction I'll use for integer D
among the list Direction offsets so now
this for loop will loop again and again
and it'll put one of these integers in
each times it runs so the first times it
run it runs D will be 0 the second time
D will be 1 and so on
so this is for D in Direction offset and
there needs to be an S and what I'll
check is if I can move in that direction
so let's go ahead and check that oh by
the way let's simplify matters a little
because we've got is active here but
there's no reason to look at directions
if you're not active so let's go ahead
and put this is active up here oh gosh
the guys of you who are following on
your laptop's must be just like frantic
at this point yes because because you
know it's like that it's very emotional
very personal so then what we'll do is
we'll check if you can
if you can move oh but wait this isn't
right what direction is now important
direction looking at currently you can
name these whatever you want the the
direction you're currently looking at is
the following first you want to look at
direction the and so we'll see deer up
here is the direction to the rally point
so we'll look at direction we'll say
okay what is oh let's see here uh
ordinal ordinal gives me which number
this is in the list of eight directions
so if I'm currently looking at north if
I that is to say if the direction of the
rally point is north then deer dot
ordinal return will return zero because
the list of directions starts with north
and in Java the index of a list starts
at zero so the first element is at zero
so deer ordinal gets me zero I'll add
and then I'll add the direction offset
number and now I will index in two
directions again so I'll say directions
direction dot values is a list of
directions and the part of that that I
take indicated by these square brackets
will be deer dot ordinal plus D I'll add
eight to make sure that it's not
negative and then I'll do mod eight the
percent eight is a mod eight and you're
gonna find this may be alien to you to
begin with but you'll find that this
kind of construction helps you out
immensely so now you're looking at a
direction currently if you can move in
that direction what you want to do is
leave this loop you don't want to stay
in the loop anymore
it's giving me this oh yes semicolon no
that's not right oh right
if I can move I forgot to put if I can
move yeah thank you for catching that me
yes if I can move the direction I am
currently looking at I want to leave
this loop so I'm throwing a lot at you
but but here you go we'll name this
thing the look-around loop and now we
can do break look around and now that
will get us out of this that will get us
out of this piece yeah
everybody likes to be splashed in nobody
nobody likes the first 27 pages of that
intro to C++ book that talks about
declaring variables and what the hell
private static beads it doesn't matter
what private static means you don't need
to know you don't need to know don't you
think I hate that I tried to learn
languages so many times here I'm
thumping the desk and and anyway I have
nothing but animosity for their correct
ways of doing things that's why I don't
study number theory my goodness yeah
because they prove like that addition
works before they do any addition I
can't imagine how they get anything done
under those circumstances so you can see
here that that nothing works at all
let's see let's see the robot is spawn
but it never moves okay so it can move
but it never actually did move that's
right so what we need to do is make it
move so within this loop we've just
exited the look-around loop that's this
one so we're just going to put our C dot
move please move please move at
currently yes and when this guy moves
he's just it tonight Oh scope oh man
these guys are smart so you see here
that this is this is inside this block
so it can't be accessed from outside so
what I'll do is I'll define it outside
and I'll just equal I'll say I'll pre
initialize it at dear and then when I
use it in here it'll be accessible to
that other look look you think I made a
mistake but it was actually deliberate
so that everybody would know about this
sort of scope problem that as you
referred to it although to be honest if
scope to me just means Listerine all
right so now what they're doing it's
it's almost it's hard to see but they're
moving around one another and they're
sort of like oscillating see that look
at that look at that yellow he's going
around and that's because you know he's
looking at the best direction that he
can go in yeah that's pretty cool what
what is going on here can I move in the
given direction where South blah blah
blah now why can't they move in that
direction is sort of an interesting
question to ask and it may
be because some of them are entirely
surrounded by other robots like this guy
for example I may end up being entirely
surrounded by the robots one of the
problems that you will encounter is that
every round robots move and they don't
remove they don't move synchronously so
it'll be really instructive if I had the
time I would show you that the number of
adjacent robots is not the number that
you might expect because this guy for
example let's say this guy wants to move
to the right let's just say he does he
can't move to the right this turn if he
executes before this guy let's say they
both want to move to the right but if
this guy executes first then he'll move
to the right that'll take place and then
when this guy looks around himself he's
gonna see an empty spot there it can be
very confusing for debugging so that's
gonna happen and you might ask okay okay
I recognize that nothing can run
synchronously because then two robots
can try to move onto the same tile and
who knows what would happen it could be
like Pauli exclusion principle is
violated two electrons occupy the same
the same orbital and and the world comes
to an end a screeching halt doesn't work
but so so here's how we do it we use the
robot ID now this is gonna come back
later so don't think that it's just an
obscure little thing this is important
so you can see here that when I click on
a robot it tells me oh is this bothering
you I can tell it's bothering half of
you and you got like a twitch developing
you're starting to shake the sweats are
coming out though sorry that's me so the
robot you can see here this is robot 38
the headquarters this robot 115 the
lower the robot number the sooner it
executes because they execute in that
order and I think when a robot dies its
number becomes available and another one
can spawn into that number in case you
wanted it that's all that's all - nitty
gritty so anyway there we've got it
let's start let's start you know owning
some noobs as it were let's destroy the
enemy it's not going to be as exciting
if we're all the same person
so let's let's not let's let's make sure
that we know who we are now one problem
here is that this only goes to rally
point let's put in an argument to
soldier code and change the name so it's
more reasonable so that it's like go
to location that's kind of that's kind
of nice and we'll give it map location
where to go yeah yeah now we'll just put
this in here and now this go to location
function can be reused
so first we'll just go to location rally
point and then after a certain number of
turns maybe then we'll just go to the
enemy base cuz we'll have all these sort
of clumped up guys will be ready to you
ready to own some noobs so let's let's
do that
let's go to the enemy base let's kill
them dead so let's say here let's say
here how are we gonna figure out what
what round it is this is sort of an
obscure function o'clock dot get round
numb I don't think that there's really
is there anything else under clock
that's worth looking at Clark get
bytecode numb oh you can get the number
of byte codes you have left that's
pretty useful so you could you could say
oh is it worth doing this computation I
don't know if I need that many extra
digits of pi so so here if if my clock
which returns an integer if that clock
number is greater than is less than 500
yea maybe 500 you know let's just make
it 200 we know we don't have all day
yeah we'll make it 200 if it's less than
200 then go to the rally point if it is
more than 200 or equal to 200 let's go
to our C dot get sense enemy yeah let's
go to the enemy let's just go ahead and
kill them so now we've got these two
pieces in here we're gonna take our
awesome robot player and we're gonna
play against hard bot yeah the bot
that's supposed to be hard on my map
tiny yeah cannot move and get well let's
just hope that that's not gonna be a
problem okay so I'm getting ready I'm
getting ready get ready for the Blitz
it's round its round 150 it's around 150
go go go yeah yeah
yes yes King dude knocking a man will be
you would be you know one thing that's
important is you got it you gotta you
know give yourself a little pat on the
back from time to time that's what
teammates are for you know to Pat each
other on the back um my brother always
used to do that he gave me a giant five
star like when you slap some was so hard
on the back that it leaves like
handprint yeah but that let me know that
he cared that was important I think
every younger brother needs that and if
you're the oldest brother in your family
then just hit the guy twice as hard so
so yeah you see here that that worked I
might just go ahead and send myself an
email saying max you sly dog you you
made a player that beats the hard bottom
mean the hard bots not actually very
hard all right all right so we've got
that that was good that was good but
maybe what we'd rather do is be sort of
more hunter like about it you know we'll
be sort of stealthy what I think would
be really cool is to go after the
closest enemy unit now you'll find in
the documentation a lot of ways of
getting enemy data like you can sense
where their encampments are and go after
those you can sense where your minds are
you can sense where its headquarters are
you can sense where the enemy robots are
and you'll probably find yourself at
some point going through a list and
trying to find like the closest enemy or
maybe the closest allied unit so we're
going to do an example of that and what
we're going to use it for is see example
this case where like they're trying to
build this encampment and they're
shooting at all of our dudes and our
dudes are just sort of like they're
getting hurt they should they should
just go gang up on that guy why aren't
they ganging up on him so let's let's
make a function for ganging up on the
enemy and it'll require that we locate
the closest enemy I mean we could
probably just go to the first one that's
in the list so I don't know which one
which one should we do in fact uh how
about this we could we could make code
yeah let's try this okay this is this is
interesting I I don't know I don't
always plan but when I do I drink no
never mind that doesn't work so let's
let's see if you can copy a package and
then we'll be able to play awesome robot
player
against awesomer robot player yeah paste
okay enter a new name oh that was
helpful I mean it's not very smart
awesome robot player copy no it's
awesome err yeah look at that and it
even changed it for me I tell you I'm
gonna be out of a job before the end of
the week so what we want to do now in
the remaining moments of lecture is we
want to find the closest enemy robot now
it may be that there are no enemy robots
this is the thing I was talking about
before let's do it let's do it okay try
so here I'm a soldier okay I don't need
to do it it from headquarters so let's
just do it if I'm a soldier we'll say
map location of the enemy robot because
after all all we currently do is go to
places we we go there and it's implied
that we kill all the things that we find
yes so the map location of the closest
enemy now let's see here this is only
gonna be valid when there are enemies
you got it you got to think about this
so let's instead do let's get all the
enemy robots so this is a robot list a
list of enemy robots some call it enemy
robots if we like doesn't matter what we
call it and we'll go our CDOT sense now
this is this is this is the hardest
thing to remember this the hardest ever
possible thing to remember since nearby
game objects this is the it's it's hard
to remember because it's so accurate
robot dot class so we want robots we
want them anywhere this is the range the
squared range that we're interested in
picking up enemies now note that these
they won't show up unless they are
within one of my allied units site range
I put in this huge number
just because I'm willing to take those
so there's I put in like a million and
then I'm gonna make sure that their
enemy by doing RC get team so that's my
team and dot opponent is a team method
that gets me the opposing team now the
two teams are team a and Team B so
that's that's literally written out as
team dot a so I could have written like
team a or team B but then I would have
had to check if I was team a or team B
so you're better off doing it this way
so I'm sensing the nearby game objects
now I need to know if that gave me any
game objects so I don't know how big
this list is if the list has a length if
enemy robots dot length is equal to zero
well then there are no enemy robots so I
should just do the same thing I was
doing before so there you go now we've
got code that should be working but if
there are robots now what have I done
here I haven't commented a single line
of code okay enemy no enemies nearby
yeah I heard somebody tell a real zinger
over there no I'm just kidding about so
no enemies okay enemy yes so someone
spotted ok enemy is enemies spotted so
yeah no that's not right I put this in
wrong spot you guys guys not helping me
not helping me nearly as much as I was
expecting so now what I'll do is I'll
loop through each of the robots now I
could do the same looping thing that I
did before where I could say like robot
a robot among enemy robots and then it
would put a robot into each one but
instead I'm going to do it a different
way just to demonstrate it I'm gonna
define an integer I equals 0 and then
I'm good and yeah there you go thank you
thank you I saw you were gonna help me
and I really appreciate it and we'll
make sure that I and and so what this is
the format for a loop that goes with
this that this type some of you are
gonna be like that's not the way that
the words work that make it explained
and I'll tell you that you are right and
and you get you get a gold medal as soon
as we mint them enemy so yeah enemy
robots dot length and we'll do I plus
plus so this will make I will go up by
one every turn so now I can type robot a
robot you know it's an enemy robot
equals enemy robots at I and now I'm
going to look through and find the
closest one now I'm sure somebody's
gonna show me a way that I'm doing it
wrong but here's how I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna keep track of which was the which
one was closest and how close it was
so in closest dist and I'm gonna
initialize it at a large number and I'm
going to do I'm gonna make it a location
because I'm and I'll do map location
closest enemy yeah closest enemy okay so
now we'll have
now this is very tricky this little bit
of sequel this little bit of sequence is
very tricky in the battlecode API when I
first did battlecode they didn't give an
example of this and it took me like 10
years to figure it out this is how to
find out where an enemy is you type RC
that's like you're starting from you
sense robot info alright and then you
pass it the robot to give sensor oh you
tell it to sense the robot info now what
does that get you
does that get you the location no that'd
be too easy so that gets you a robot
info object if you so that now you've
got robot info a robot info equals that
so now I've got some robot info robot
info is yet another one of these classes
so here in the Java Doc's I look at this
I keep opening more and more of them I
said another one there's another one
they're multiplying so here you could
see the robot info there it was so you
can see that information about the enemy
robots can be things like the amount of
shields they have the type of robot its
location one of the robot info things is
robot so what you can do is you can
sense the robot you can you can get the
robot since its info and then do info
dot robot and then sense that things
info and then you'll have the info so
you can go back to the robot and it'll
be a really nice little loop it's
wonderful it's just mmm just great I
highly recommend that kind of code it's
just it's just you know warms my heart
so you know like does it what does it
what like a little kid does is that like
computationally impressive no but it's
cute so it warms you anyway so that's
that was that that was the reasoning
behind that crazy stream of logic so
they here we go we got robot info
let's check the distance and be done
with it so we'll say that the distance
which is an integer equals a robot info
dot location dot distance squared - of
course you can write your own distance
squared - metric or something or other
but we're just going to do it this way
and we're gonna make it the distance
from I guess it could be myself as the
robot so distance squared - hmm hmm it's
sort of hard to decide it could be the
one that's closest to me or uh let's
just do me for the moment maybe
we'll make it more complicated actually
gonna run out of time we're just gonna
end up eating Indian food but that's
wonderful
it's really how many of you have eaten
it at India samraat that place is
fantastic Wow oh my goodness you're in
suck you're in for such a treat I don't
know if it's gonna if it's gonna be
considered the same level of treat as Oh
anywhere I'm just going on and on it
this so if if the distance that we're
currently looking at is less than the
closest dist then we'll say that it is
the new closest dist and we will assign
closest enemy equals
it is at well I didn't I didn't record
it anywhere it's this one yes so there
it is that's the closest enemy so once
again if there were no enemies nearby we
would either go to the rally point or
go-to location but now what we want to
do oh goodness
hey quit quit sending me things on them
anyway so now what we'll do is we'll
just go straight to the enemy that's
what we'll do if we see one we'll go
kill him so now what we'll do is we'll
pick this code against the previous
version of this code and we'll see which
one wins it's sort of an interesting
question which code is better to go
straight for the enemy base or to go for
the closest enemy robot because maybe on
their way to the base I mean everybody
shoots on their way to everywhere but
what's the best thing I think I think
it'll be quite interesting so let's see
where do we shoot it's here so now we
can go to the location and we can go to
the closest enemy yeah cuz there's
guaranteed to be an enemy to go to Oh
bother it's another one of these things
no wait that's that's their go-to
location closest enemy oh right I got to
initialize it yes so we're putting null
it'll never see null but I got to put it
there anyway so that it's comforted I
believe that's the technical explanation
for what's going on in the background of
Eclipse I'm pretty sure so now let's run
oh man this is getting exciting it's
5:55 i guess well well I'll have like
some closing remarks but this will be
the thing that like is supposed to be
exciting and amazing
we'll have awesome vs. awesomer all
right and ah but these guys these guys
are soaked they have a lot of
that's so important I didn't say that
again all right so raise your hand if
you think that awesome robot player the
original one that the original awesome
is gonna win three hands how many people
think that awesomer robot is gonna win
four hands man okay well you know I
recognized that premature arthritis can
be caused by coding raising an arm maybe
beyond some of us in terms of like oh
okay
we're gonna find out okay I actually
don't know the answer okay so they're
just they're just sort of they're just
grouping it's round 70 it's around eight
it's around 100 and round 200 exciting
stuffs gonna happen I wish we could slow
this down it's gonna happen all at once
boom oh all but they stop there they
went if they stop there the awesomer
player is one hooray
did you see that it was all too fast you
saw it just went by before I mean before
I even noticed it was it was ah goodness
gracious so here it goes
these these guys will run back to the
base but these guys will be following
them the whole way through
okay so let's let's back it up a little
bit this is sort of interesting now I
think if you push like F or B or C you
can turn off the circles maybe not okay
so they're sort of forming a concave oh
man a lot of them are blowing up it's
kind of hard to tell what's going on
okay so here it looks pretty darn even
one two three four five six seven eight
nine versus one I can't tell if he's
dying two three four five six seven
eight nine ten okay so it's ten versus
nine the blue guys have done well pretty
pretty well already
oh boy then they just like Bing they
just ping and turn around and kill
everything I got it I got a step forward
more slowly this is this is a fast-paced
game let me tell you let me tell you
you're not gonna be here for an hour you
know watching somebody oh man okay so
these guys are all working over there
oh look at that look at that meanwhile
like these guys are ganging up on him
and these three guys are getting totally
double-teamed or quadruple teamed or
whatever the word is by these fellows oh
I'm pointing with my finger how can you
see that
oh goodness yeah look I'm enjoying
myself okay
yeah and then they turn around and they
kill the enemy and then they can't turn
around they kill the enemy base there
you have it boom done all right so final
closing remarks closing remarks I'm
looking at the wrong page yeah so
improvements to this robot you know
there's lots of things that you could do
that you would do that that are worth
doing like for example everybody's
making decisions independently you could
be using messaging I think I think this
is a big this is a big point because a
lot somebody asked me the other day what
is the point of messaging because all of
my robots have access to all of my other
robots data and you saw that happen here
because would these guys have been able
to respond intelligently like like would
this guy have come gosh I'm using my
finger again with these fellows be able
to come all the way back I agree Steven
I should close gchat when presenting
should would these guys have been able
to come all the way back to here if they
couldn't if they didn't have shared data
no they wouldn't so they have shared
data why would you ever use messaging
because you could simplify it by having
your headquarters do the processing and
say all right I want everybody to attack
this guy and then they all just go ahead
and follow that command rather than
having to do the processing themselves
because if everybody has the same data
why should everybody process on the same
data so there you go that is a reason
it's not it doesn't prove that it's
always better because it may be much
better to have a decentralized approach
and so on there are very many reasons
but there you go that's an answer to
that question you saw awesome
you saw awesome ER and you saw it right
here thank you for coming the next just
you know remain calm in your seats and
there will be food the food got probably
arrived already I'm sorry yesterday I
thought the food guy hadn't arrived they
don't they don't mind being called food
guys don't worry it's not insulting I I
thought he hadn't arrived but yeah I
think he was like poking his head in and
out like a drinking bird and I just
didn't see it because of like you know
various myopia and such know that what
do they call it tunnel vision so yes the
next lecture I'm sure you enjoyed this
one a lot even if you know Java already
you
you could you could see the warmth and
the smiles on the faces of the people
who didn't know Java and now due because
of this amazing whirlwind tour so they
yes the next lecture will be on
navigation as if this one wasn't yeah
and you're gonna hear all kinds of
amazing things that you never would have
expected and you're gonna see this sort
of like awesome visualizer that's a
little bit like the fractals that I was
showing before it's made in Mathematica
and it's made in the USA and yeah hooray
so thank you for coming and this is the
end of lecture and I'll just be here
answering questions again this lab after
lecture oh my god this is like one of
those symphonies that you think keeps
ending but it doesn't end and that and
that'll be all thank you